les animaux se donnent en spectacle au
Musée du Jouet de Poissy l'exposition
petite bête de tout poil propose de
plonger le spectateur dans l'histoire
des jouets animaliers singes cochon chat
ou encore éléphant une visite adressée
avant tout aux enfants mais pas
seulement c'est aussi destiné à des gens
qui s'intéressent à l'histoire du jouet
à des gens qui veulent retourner en
enfance parce que c'est vrai que c'est
un vrai bain de jouvence de se promener
dans ce musée en retrouvant des
souvenirs en découvrant des des jouets
qu'on n'aurait pas imaginé une
exposition pensée de manière
chronologique animaux mécaniques du
début du 20e siècle mais aussi objet de
l'antiquité grâce à un dépôt du musée du
Louvre les gens qui sont en terre cuite
un bélier à roulettes qui vient de
d'Iran mais également des petits ce
qu'on pourrait appeler des ancêtres
duochet qui sont des petits jouets
sonores en forme de hérisson en forme de
cochon en forme d'oiseaux le plus ancien
connu est un petit oiseau en argile qui
date du 19e siècle avant Jésus-Christ
alors ici dans cette vitrine un autre
type de jouet qui est assez original
c'est ce dindon à bascule à travers tout
le musée on voit beaucoup de chevaux à
bascule le cheval est un animal noble et
qui était un animal très proche de
l'homme et là on a une petite touche un
peu humoristique avec le choix de cet
animal de ferme un petit peu ridicule
qui a été fabriqué dans les ateliers des
mutilés de guerre qui était des ateliers
construits après la Première Guerre
mondiale pour donner un emploi à des
soldats qui avaient été blessés pendant
la Première Guerre mondiale cette
vitrine expose les jeux animaliers de
1850 à 1910 comme le jeu d'adresse Tobi
le principe envoyé des anneaux grâce à
un système à ressort sur la trompe de
l'éléphant ou sur les cibles du tapis ce
jeu de Toby en fait était inspiré par un
véritable éléphant qui venait du zoo de
Sydney et qui a voyagé le pauvre
j'imagine dans des conditions un peu
difficiles pendant tout le début du 20e
siècle dans tous les eaux européens
l'exposition petite bête de tout poil se
poursuit jusqu'au 9 juillet 2023 pour
continuer à plonger vos enfants dans
l'univers animalier divers ateliers et
spectacles sont proposés pendant les
vacances scolaires